Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Octavian launched his campaign in the first weeks of 33 BC. He began in the Senate with the latest reports of Antony's behaviour. What, he asked, was going on in Alexandria? What had happened to his old comrade? What could explain all these un-Roman antics? Every day the stories became more shocking. Antony had adopted
感谢收听《历史的余烬》（The Rest Is History）。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先收听系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。公元前 33 年的头几周，屋大维发动了政治攻势。他首先在元老院宣读了安东尼最新行为的报告。他质问，亚历山大城到底在发生什么？他昔日的战友究竟怎么了？这一切充满非罗马风范的怪异举动该如何解释？每天都有更加耸人听闻的故事流传开来。安东尼竟然皈依了
all kinds of strange Egyptian cults. He'd lost his Roman virtues and become a slave to luxury. He lazed around all day on a gilded couch, wearing a jewel-encrusted robe and carrying an oriental scepter. He spent all his time drinking the local wine and went to the toilet in a chamber pot of solid gold. He feasted every night on weird un-Roman dishes, enthralled to the whims of his Egyptian queen, and at palace banquets he even massaged her feet like a slave. So that is from a top children's book about the life of Cleopatra, Queen of the Nile. You can guess the author. So Tom Holland, that's Octavian's propaganda,
各种奇奇怪怪的埃及异教。他已经丧失了罗马人的美德，沦为了穷奢极欲的奴隶。他整天懒洋洋地斜躺在镀金长椅上，身穿镶满珠宝的长袍，手持东方权杖。他把所有时间都用来畅饮当地的美洒，甚至用纯金便盆上厕所。他每晚都享用着奇特且不符合罗马传统的饕餮盛宴，任由他的埃及女王摆布；在宫廷宴会上，他甚至像个奴隶一样给她按摩双脚。这段话出自一本关于尼罗河女王克娄巴特拉生平的畅销儿童读物。大家可以猜猜作者是谁。汤姆·霍兰，这就是屋大维的宣传机器，
talking about Antony and Cleopatra. It reminds me of how another writer described it. Antony, the triple pillar of the world transformed into a strumpet's fool. So that's Shakespeare. Very nice. Well, I mean, they're the two great literary figures of the western world so so so that tradition is absolutely the tradition i think that dominates the popular understanding of antony cleopatra that that antony is has been
在议论安东尼和克娄巴特拉。这让我想起另一位作家是如何描述他们的。安东尼，这个世界的擎天三柱，竟堕落为一个荡妇的玩物。这就是莎士比亚的词句。非常美妙。我的意思是，他们是西方世界仅有的两位伟大文学巨匠，因此这种传统绝对构成了大众对安东尼与克娄巴特拉认知的主流，即安东尼被
kind of softened and corrupted and in literally enslaved by Cleopatra. And that's where we left the last episode. So we've done three. We are now around about, what are we, sort of 34, 33 BC. Antony and Cleopatra in Alexandria. Octavian is beginning the propaganda campaign against them, which has sort of been simmering for the last few years, but now really reaches. So Octavian needs, I think to Octavian had always set his heart on establishing his supremacy over Rome and the whole world. I think that had always been his object. And I think he pursues it with a
克娄巴特拉彻底软化、腐蚀并奴化了。这就是我们上一期节目结束的地方。我们已经讲了三期。现在时间大约是，我们看看，大概是公元前 34 或 33 年。安东尼和克娄巴特拉在亚历山大城。屋大维正开始对他们展开宣传攻势，这种攻势在过去几年里一直在暗中酝酿，但现在真正达到了高潮。因此屋大维需要，我认为屋大维一直铁了心要确立他对罗马乃至全世界的至高统治地位。我认为这一直是他的目标。而且我认为他带着一种
kind of chill ruthlessness. And he has a kind of penetrating and slightly cold political intelligence that enables him to recognise that Antony's strategy is a massive source of potential for him. Yeah. Well, I was about to say, doesn't he realise that Cleopatra is in some ways Antony's greatest asset, but she's also his great weakness. Cleopatra is a weapon for Octavian and I think that's the brilliance that he recognizes that he can turn Antony's great strength against him well so the big challenge that Octavian faces if he's to knock out Antony is that the Romans you know don't want civil war they've had two brutal bouts of it um Octavian's pitch is that he is bringing them peace. So if he launches an attack on Antony, that would be unacceptable. The Roman people would not get behind him.
冷酷无情的态度去追求这个目标。他拥有某种敏锐且略显冷酷的政治智慧，这使他能够清醒地认识到，安东尼的战略对他而言是一座巨大的潜力宝库。是的。我正想说，难道他没意识到克娄巴特拉在某些方面是安东尼最大的资产，但同时也是他最大的软肋吗？克娄巴特拉是屋大维手中的一件武器，我认为这就是他高明的地方——他意识到自己可以把安东尼最大的优势反戈一击。屋大维要想击溃安东尼，他面临的最大挑战是，罗马人其实并不想爆发内战，他们已经经历过两次残酷的内战了；嗯，屋大维的宣传基调是他正在为他们带来和平。因此，如果他主动对安东尼发动进攻，那是不可接受的。罗马人民不会支持他。
The Western provinces would not get behind him. The Italians would not get behind him. However, if he can present the war as a campaign against Cleopatra, then that's completely different. And Cleopatra is in every way a kind of ideal bogey, because she is foreign, she is royal, and she is female. So on every level, every level of Roman political prejudice, that makes her a sinister opponent. Let's talk about that last element because we've we're into the fourth podcast now in this series and we've talked a little bit about Cleopatra as a woman and as that rarity a woman exercising political power but we should perhaps
西方行省不会支持他。意大利人也不会支持他。然而，如果他能将这场战争包装成一场针对克娄巴特拉的战役，情况就完全不同了。克娄巴特拉在各个方面都是一个理想的“眼中钉”，因为她是外国人，她是王室成员，而且她是个女性。因此，在罗马政治偏见的每一个层面，这都使她成为一个充满威胁的对手。让我们来谈谈最后一个要素，因为这是我们这个系列的第四期播客了，我们之前稍微讨论过克娄巴特拉作为女性的身份，以及她作为一个罕见的、行使政治权力的女性的特质，但我们或许应该
dig a tiny bit more into that because do you think that's what makes her so unsettling because some biographers particularly female biographers have suggested that suggested that there's a sort of bucket loads of misogyny in this. I think there absolutely are. And that the Romans, there was something peculiarly horrific to Roman elite male opinion about a woman leader, a foreign woman. Do you think that's true? Do you think it's the femininity that makes Cleopatra so shocking? I think it's part of the package. So the historian W. W. Tarn, who was a kind of splendid representative of mid-century Classus tradition, said of Cleopatra that she was Hannibal's only rival as an enemy of Rome,
再深入挖掘一点，因为你认为正是这一点让她如此令人不安吗？因为一些传记作家，特别是女性传记作家曾指出，这里面充斥着大量的厌女情绪。我认为确实如此。而且对于罗马精英男性的观点来说，女性统治者——尤其是外国女性统治者——具有某种极其恐怖的意味。你认为这是真的吗？你认为正是这种女性特质让克娄巴特拉如此令人震惊吗？我认为这是其中一部分原因。因此，历史学家 W. W. 坦（W. W. Tarn），他是世纪中期古典学传统的一位杰出代表，曾这样评价克娄巴特拉：作为罗马的敌人，她仅次于汉尼拔，
that she inspired almost as much terror in the Romans as Hannibal did. And I think that that's a judgment that kind of overdoes it. I don't think she was ever on a level with Hannibal. But I think that it does respond correctly to the scale of the propaganda effort that Octavian unleashes. But as is always the case with propaganda, it only works if you're going with the grain of prejudices that already exist. And the idea of Cleopatra as a woman feminizing men, there's a whole set kind of sexual dynamic there that I think is hard for us to get a handle on because it's very, very alien to us. But essentially for Romans, the idea of a man being feminized is absolutely the most shocking thing that you could contemplate. The idea that a man plays a woman, you know, to a man, let alone to a woman is absolutely the worst taboo. And so by presenting Antony in that light,
她给罗马人带来的恐惧几乎不亚于汉尼拔。我认为这种评价有点夸大其词了。我不认为她曾达到过与汉尼拔同等的地位。但我认为这确实恰如其分地反映了屋大维发动的那场宣传攻势的规模。不过，正如宣传一向如此，它只有在迎合既有偏见的情况下才能发挥作用。关于克娄巴特拉通过女性特质来弱化男性的这种观点，其中包含着一整套微妙的性爱动力学，我认为我们很难完全理解，因为它对我们来说极其陌生。但从根本上讲，对罗马人来说，一个男人被女性化绝对是他们所能想象到的最令人震惊的事情。一个男人扮演女性的角色，你知道的，对一个男人而言，更不用说对一个女人而言了，这绝对是最大的禁忌。因此，通过这种视角来塑造安东尼，
you know, it's kind of, you know, it's like saying he's a, you know, in our lights, a kind of paedophile or something. I mean, it's on that level of shock and horror. So that's what Antony's, that's what Octavian's doing. But he is also, of course, saying that Antony has ceased to be be Roman that he's become a kind of you know a soft decadent depraved Greekling from the east and that's why and also that he wants to become a king and I think the the the the kind of monarchical strain is true I think that that is what Anthony's playing with and I think that you know that's a cause of you know it enables him to draw support in the east but of course it I mean, it's anathema to people in Rome
你知道的，这有点像，你知道的，就相当于在现代语境下说他是个恋童癖之类的人。我的意思是，它是处于那种级别的震惊和恐怖之中。这就是安东尼的，这就是屋大维正在做的事情。但与此同时，他当然也在宣称安东尼已经不再是罗马人，他变成了一个温吞、颓废、堕落的东方式希腊小人，正因如此，而且他还想当国王。我认为这种君主制的倾向是真实存在的，我认为这正是安东尼在尝试的事情，而且我认为，你知道的，这也是一个原因，这使他在东方能够赢得支持，但当然，我的意思是，这对于罗马人来说简直是十恶不赦，
for whom the word king is absolutely a dirty word. And around about this point, Tom, I think that we get a lot of the stories. So for example, there's a story about people dressing up as a friend of theirs called Plankus, who dresses up as a sea nymph at their parties, sort of wriggling around, covered in blue. There's the story about one of the famous Cleopatra stories
在罗马人眼中，“国王”这个词绝对是个脏话。就在这个节骨眼上，汤姆，我们听到很多这样的故事。比如，有个故事说人们打扮成一个叫普兰库斯（Plancus）的朋友，他在聚会上打扮成一个海中仙女，扭动着身子，浑身涂满蓝色。还有一个关于克娄巴特拉的著名故事，
that historians have spent a lot of time arguing about. Was it chemically possible and all this thing about her swallowing a pearl? Which comes from very much my friend, Pliny the Elder. Yeah. So that's the story that she has a bet with Antony that she can basically serve the most expensive meal that's ever been served in human history. And she dissolves a pearl in vinegar and drinks it.
历史学家们花了很多时间去争论：这在化学上是可能的吗？也就是她吞下一颗珍珠的事儿。这个故事主要出自我的好朋友老普林尼。没错。故事讲的是她和安东尼打赌，说自己能端出人类历史上最奢侈的一顿饭。然后她把一颗珍珠溶解在醋里并喝了下去。
And people, scholars have actually written articles about, you know, the chemical composition of pearls and whether this would be possible had she softened the pearl beforehand. But isn't the obvious explanation for all these stories that they are produced by Octavian's propagandists and then they turn up in plinian and plutarch and cassius dio and so on yes do you think there's a grain of truth in them do you think some of these things probably happened it's very difficult to know isn't it um i i think a bit of both i i think anthony has the misfortune that um so octavian has two henchmen one of whom agrippa has set up this navy he's a brilliant naval commander um a brilliant military man which octavian absolutely isn't uh but his second right hand man is a guy called mycenas who is brilliant at spotting literary talent he basically is peter
学者们甚至还专门撰文探讨珍珠的化学成分，以及如果事先把珍珠软化，这是否可能实现。但对所有这些故事，难道不有一个显而易见的解释吗？它们都是由屋大维的宣传机器炮制出来的，后来又出现在普林尼、普鲁塔克以及卡西乌斯·狄奥等人的著作中。没错，你认为其中包含着一丝真相吗？你认为这些事情中有些可能真的发生过吗？这很难说，不是吗？嗯，我认为两者皆有。我认为安东尼很不幸，因为屋大维手下有两名得力干将：其中一人是阿格里帕，他建立了一支舰队，是一位出色的海军统帅，也是一位杰出的军事人才——而屋大维自己绝对不是；但屋大维的第二大助手是一个名叫麦世那（Maecenas）的人，他极其擅长发掘文学人才。他基本上就是彼得·曼德尔森（Peter Mandelson），对吧？不，好吧，他是个文学迷，从某种程度上讲是这样的。但我的意思是，他确实有鉴赏文学人才的眼光，所以他发掘了一些世界上最伟大的诗人们，也就是罗马文学那些伟大的巨匠——普罗佩提乌斯、贺拉斯，当然还有伟大的维吉尔。正是他们的天才，确保了那些原本可能只是粗俗宣传的东西，最终被编织成了流传后世的伟大诗篇。然而这里还有一个更深层的悖论：正因为他们是伟大的诗人们，他们不仅仅是在进行人身攻击。他们还能够在长远之计上，为他们的描写赋予某种尊严——对克娄巴特拉的描写如此，对安东尼在一定程度上也是如此，尤其是对克娄巴特拉，这在塑造她日后声誉的浪漫色彩和影响力方面发挥了至关重要的作用。最著名的例子，
mandelton isn't he no well he's but he's a literary yeah to a degree but i mean he he has an eye for literary talent so he identifies some of the world's greatest poets you know the great great writers of roman literature it's propitious horace and of course bubble virgil yeah and it's their genius that will ensure that what might otherwise have just been kind of crude propaganda becomes woven into poetry that has been read ever since. But there is a further paradox, which is that because they are great poets, they're not just dealing in abuse. They are also able to give, in the long run, a kind of dignity to their portrayal, certainly of Cleopatra and also to a degree of Antony as well, but particularly to Cleopatra, which plays a crucial role in the kind of the romance and the potency of her subsequent reputation. So the famous example,
其中最著名的例子莫过于维吉尔撰写的罗马开国史诗《埃涅阿斯纪》。埃涅阿斯是一位特洛伊王子，神明告诉他必须逃离特洛伊，率领一众特洛伊人乘船航行，最终他将建立一座日后催生罗马建城的城市。但他中途在一个刚刚在北非海岸建立的城市停了下来，这座城市叫迦太基，由一位名叫狄多（Dido）的女王建立。埃涅阿斯经受不住诱惑，想要留下来，忽视了神明赋予他的神圣使命——去开启罗马的血脉，而是选择和狄多厮混在一起。最后，神明提醒他：快动身吧，你还得去开创罗马的历史。于是埃涅阿斯离开了，狄多则自杀了。据说这就奠定了
the most famous example of this would be in the Aeneid, the great epic of Roman beginnings that Virgil writes. And Aeneas is a Trojan prince who has been told by the gods that he has to flee Troy, sail with a band of Trojans, and he will end up founding the city that in due course will result in the foundation of Rome. But he stops off in a city that has just been founded on the North African coast called Carthage, which has been founded by a queen called Dido. And Aeneas is tempted to stay and ignore his divine destiny to go off and kind of found the Roman line and hang out with Dido. And in the end, he gets reminded by the gods, get a move on, you've got to go and found Roman history. So Aeneas goes and Dido commits suicide. And this supposedly establishes
罗马与迦太基之间世代的仇恨，并最终以迦太基的灭亡告终。但其重要意义在于，这显然是在呼应安东尼和克娄巴特拉的故事。实际上，狄多被塑造成一个非常、非常令人同情的人物。她所具有的潜力和力量，也与贺拉斯的诗作遥相呼应——尽管他在诗中对克娄巴特拉极其粗鲁，却又忍不住让她显得迷人而充满魅力。当然，这确实抹黑了她的声誉，这意味着所有这些将她视作色欲熏心的悍妇的传统，绝对进入了文化主流，并且被一次又一次、一遍又一遍地反复炒作。但它们也确保了她——她作为一位非凡女性、一位非凡领袖的人物形象，以及那个能够俘获世界上两位最伟大男人的心的女人——这也成为了神话的一部分。所以，这是一份复杂的遗产。
the lifelong hatred between Rome and Carthage that will culminate in Carthage's destruction. But the significance of that is that it's obviously making play with the story of Antony and Cleopatra. And actually, Dido is presented very, very sympathetically. She has a potency and a power that is also echoed in the poetry of Horace, where he's very rude about Cleopatra, but he can't help but make her seem glamorous and fascinating. certainly blackens her reputation and it means that you know all these kind of traditions of her as a sex mad virago absolutely pass into the kind of cultural mainstream and have been recycled and recycled and recycled but they have also ensured that she you know her character as a remarkable woman a remarkable leader um someone who could uh capture the heart of a two of the greatest men in the world that that is also a part of the myth. So it's a complicated legacy.
汤姆，在我们回到地缘政治以及军事叙事之前，我只想问一个问题：安东尼与克娄巴特拉（或者说狄多与埃涅阿斯）的这种肖像画般的描写，在多大程度上要归功于伊阿宋与美狄亚这样的故事？因为，我的意思是，他们对那个故事都耳熟能详，对吧？这就是“妖后”与“易骗英雄”的套路。我的意思是，这恰恰就是安东尼和克娄巴特拉的故事，不是吗？好吧，还是那句话，你问这里面有多少成分根植于厌女情绪。
Just one question, Tom, before we get back to the geopolitics, as it were, and sort of the military narrative. How much do you think that portrait of Antony and Cleopatra or indeed Dido and Aeneas owes to things like Jason and Medea? Because, I mean, they would all have been familiar with that story, right? And that's the idea of the witch queen and the sort of gullible hero. I mean, that's really the Antony and Cleopatra story right there, isn't it? Well, again, you know, you asked how much of this is rooted in misogyny.
许多这类神话，都将对外国王室的戒备与对女性的戒备融合在了一起，因为在希腊和罗马的传统中，外国君王都等同于柔弱和女性化。是的，所以，
A lot of these myths, they fuse suspicion of foreign royalty with suspicion of the female because in both the greek and the roman traditions foreign kings are equated with with effeminacy yeah so um a woman is an ideal representative of these kind of traditions and of course i mean all these all this propaganda is going with the grain of that uh that's why that's why it's so effective and why it works all right so let's move on from the propaganda to the sort of the hard political and military realities so the breach really becomes obvious at the beginning of 32 bc i would say that's when the two consuls pro-antony cons, they flee Rome, don't they, with about a third of the Senate to the east. It's a bit of a, this is a slight action replay of. Yeah.
女性是这类传统的理想代表。当然，我的意思是，所有这些宣传都顺应了这种偏见的发展方向，这就是为什么它如此有效，为什么它能发挥作用。好吧，让我们从宣传转向那些残酷的政治与军事现实。决裂在公元前 32 年初变得显而易见，我认为正是在那时，两位亲安东尼的执政官，他们带着大约三分之一的元老院成员逃往了东方。这有点像，这稍微有点像历史重演。
And one of them is Domitius Ahenobarbus, who in Shakespeare's play is Ahenobarbus. Who is the guy who has those wonderful lines. So Anthony and Cleopatra have moved to Ephesus and they receive the senators there. And it's pretty obvious at this point isn't it war hasn't been declared um but it's obvious that there's going to be a civil war won't be declared as a civil war will it I mean that's the key thing it will be declared as a war against Cleopatra
其中一人是多米蒂乌斯·阿赫诺巴尔布斯（Domitius Ahenobarbus），在莎士比亚的戏剧中他就是阿赫诺巴尔布斯。就是那个说出那些精彩台词的人。所以安东尼和克娄巴特拉已经搬到了以弗所，并在那里接见了元老院议员。此时局势已经相当明朗了，对吧？战争尚未宣战，但很明显将会爆发内战。这场战争不会以“内战”的名义宣战，对吧？我的意思是，关键在于：它将以讨伐克娄巴特拉的名义宣战。
Antony and Cleopatra are in Ephesus and at this point some of Antony's friends say even at this stage I think you should send her back to Egypt. She's a problem because even though she's providing a lot of the money and the fleet, Italy will never accept her. And actually, one of his friends, a man called Gaminius, gets drunk and
安东尼和克娄巴特拉身处以弗所，此时安东尼的一些朋友甚至在这个阶段建议：“我认为你应该把她送回埃及。她是个麻烦，因为尽管她提供了大量的资金和舰队，但意大利永远不会接受她。”事实上，他的一个朋友，一个叫盖米尼乌斯（Gaminius）的人，喝醉了酒，
says, we'd be better off without her. And Cleopatra, according to the sources, says oh that's great I'm glad you've said that because now we no longer need to torture you to find out what you really think and he then Giminez then flees to Octavian but that I mean whether or not that story is true we don't know but there's clearly there's a sort of um there's a there's a discipline and a focus on Octavian's side that there isn't on Anttony's side and that part of the reason for that would you say thomas that the cleopatra is a destabilizing element to the other roman
说道：“没有她，我们可能会过得更好。”而根据史料记载，克娄巴特拉说道：“太好了，我很高兴你这么说，因为现在我们不再需要对你用刑来逼问你的真实想法了。”随后，盖米尼乌斯便投奔了屋大维。但是，不管这个故事是否属实，我们无从得知；但很显然，屋大维阵营有一种安东尼阵营所没有的纪律性和专注度。汤姆，你会说部分原因在于克娄巴特拉对其他罗马将领来说是一个破坏稳定的因素吗？
captains absolutely yes yes and so that's that's the problem that antony faces is that perforce i mean he hasn't really had a choice because he's based in alexandria not not in rome but he has to found his pitch for the world in alliance with cleopatra and of course that that that destabilizes his own side and it enables octavian to present himself as the defender of of rome against sinister foreign barbarian queens because the next thing octavian does is the will and yeah now what so what's the story there what's going on because that will seem slightly baffling to people who are not familiar with sort of the legal niceties of kind of roman anthony has deposited his will with the festal virgins who are the guardians of the hearth fire of rome itself in the Forum, the kind of great central space in Rome.
绝对是的，没错。所以，这就是安东尼所面临的困境：他别无选择，因为他的大本营在亚历山大城，而不是罗马，但他必须以与克娄巴特拉结盟为基础来确立他在世界上的地位。当然，这动摇了他自己阵营的军心，也让屋大维得以将自己塑造成罗马的捍卫者，来对抗阴险的外国蛮族女王。因为屋大维接下来做的事情就是公开遗嘱。
And, you know, it's absolutely sacrosanct. No question of anyone being allowed to look at it. So Octavian goes and grabs it and reads it out to the Senate. And it's full of shocking details. So Antony acknowledges that Caesarian is Julius Caesar's heir again in the will, which is incendiary. Striking at Octavian. Obviously, blow at Octavian.
那么，这背后的故事是什么？到底是怎么回事？因为对于不熟悉罗马法律细节的人来说，这份遗嘱听起来有点匪夷所思。安东尼将他的遗嘱交给了维斯塔贞女（Vestal Virgins），她们是罗马圣火的守护者，圣火位于罗马广场（Forum）——罗马的宏大中心空间内。
He leaves property to Cleopatra, which is that not illegal under Roman law to leave property to a foreigner? And according to Octavian, because Octavian is the person who reads it out, right? So we don't know. We don't know what his... Octavian could be making it all up.
而且，这绝对是神圣不可侵犯的。根本不可能允许任何人查阅。所以屋大维跑去夺取了遗嘱，并在元老院宣读了它。里面充满了令人震惊的细节。比如，安东尼在遗嘱中再次承认恺撒里昂（Caesarian）是尤利乌斯·恺撒的合法继承人，这极具煽动性。这是在打击屋大维。显然，这是对屋大维的沉重打击。
But Octavian says that Antony, perhaps most shockingly, wants to be buried after his death in Alexandria, not in Rome. Do you think all that's true? Do you think Antony did? Had he gone native, as it were? We don't know. My hunch would be no, but that it's untrue only to the degree that people would accept it was true.
他将财产留给克娄巴特拉。根据罗马法律，将财产留给外国人难道不是违法的吗？而根据屋大维的说法——因为宣读遗嘱的人正是屋大维，对吧？所以我们无从得知。我们不知道他的……屋大维完全可能是凭空捏造的。
I'm just trying to figure that out. Yes, okay. It's probably heightened, but it's not so heightened that people weren't able to believe it because people clearly did believe it yeah and so it's after that that octavian stages this ceremony which appears to be an old-fashioned ceremony but he may have invented is that right so yeah it kind of involves throwing a spear and all this kind of um very self-conscious kind of antiquarian is a bit like Victorians inventing traditions, you know, passing them off as time-honored. And so it identifies Octavian with the ancient, you know, the martial traditions of Rome, where you declare war on a barbarian enemy and you hurl a spear and priests do all kinds of stuff. And he does that.
但屋大维声称，安东尼最令人震惊的愿望，或许是在他死后要求被埋葬在亚历山大城，而不是罗马。你认为这一切都是真的吗？你认为安东尼真的这样想吗？他当时是不是已经“本土化”了？我们无从得知。我的直觉是不会，但它失实也仅仅在于人们愿意相信它是真的程度之内。
And also very, an absolute novelty. He gets communities across Italy and the West to swear kind of oath of loyalty to him as the commander of the Roman effort against this barbarian queen. So now we're into the war. War has basically been declared. Antony and Cleopatra are in the East. They're basically in Patras in Greece. Octavian and Cleopatra are in the east. They're basically in Patras in Greece. Octavian is going to try and cross from Italy. And now the baffling thing to me here is what Antony's strategy is. Because Antony, it really matters to him that he has to keep the sea lanes to Alexandria open.
我正试图弄清楚这一点。是的，好吧。这可能被夸大了，但还没有夸大到人们无法相信的地步，因为当时的人们显然深信不疑。正是在那之后，屋大维举行了这样一场仪式：这看起来像是一场古老的仪式，但也可能是他自己发明的，是这样吗？所以，这有点像是掷长矛以及所有这类非常刻意的、具有古玩收藏家风格的举动。这就像维多利亚时代的人发明传统，然后把它们伪装成历史悠久的东西一样。因此，这确立了屋大维作为罗马古老尚武传统的继承人的形象——即当你向一个蛮族敌人宣战时，你会掷出一根长矛，祭司们则会做各种各样的法事。他确实这么做了。
Because obviously that's the supplies of his fleet. He also wants to keep hold of Greece. But Octavian strikes east. Agrippa takes his fleet and kind of hoovers up of greece but octavian strikes east agrippa takes his fleet and kind of hoovers up some of the ports on the peloponnese octavian crosses his with his land army to corfu and then to epirus what i don't what i've never really understood is how it happens that anthony manages to end up being cornered without really having fought any battles he's they get bottled up so they get bottled up in the bay of actium exactly and which is so it's the gulf of ambracia it's a place called
此外，还有一个绝对史无前例的举动：他让意大利和西方各地的社区向他宣誓效忠，拥戴他为对抗这个蛮族女王的罗马军事统帅。好了，现在我们进入了战争状态。战争基本上已经打响了。安东尼和克娄巴特拉身处东方。他们基本上驻扎在希腊的帕特雷（Patras）。屋大维和克娄巴特拉在东方。他们基本上驻扎在希腊的帕特雷。屋大维将试图从意大利渡海。现在，让我感到困惑的是安东尼的战略究竟是什么。因为对安东尼来说，保持通往亚历山大城的海上航线畅通至关重要。
actium it's a sort of fly bitten it's like is it a fishing port i mean it's yeah it's pretty much basically isn't it how is it that i mean what's what explains his passivity because he basically allows octavian and agrippa to blockade him in this crescent big crescent shaped bay and i mean why is why doesn't he take the fight to the enemy he wants to fight a land war octavian refuses to fight it and because his ships are blockaded the option is either to starve or to fight or to try and make a run for it with the ships or to fight fight a sea battle. Yeah. So those are the options. And this is the sort of uncertainty, isn't it? Because it's the summer of 31 BC.
因为显然后勤补给全靠这些舰队。他还想守住希腊。但屋大维向东挺进，阿格里帕率领他的舰队横扫了希腊的部分港口。屋大维率领他的陆军横渡到科孚岛，然后抵达伊庇鲁斯。我一直真正搞不懂的是，安东尼怎么会在几乎没打过什么仗的情况下就陷入绝境？他们被包围了。所以他们被死死封锁在亚克兴湾（Bay of Actium）里，正是安布拉基亚湾（Gulf of Ambracia），一个叫亚克兴（Actium）的地方。那是个有些荒凉的、像是个渔港的地方，差不多就是这样，对吧？
Antony is there. Cleopatra is there. They're blockaded in Actium, which is in kind of northwestern Greece. Agrippa's ships blockading them. And they have this great debate. Do we break out by land or by sea? And most of the Roman officers seem to have wanted to break out by land. Because obviously,
怎么会这样呢？我的意思是，是什么导致了他的消极应战？因为他基本上任由屋大维和阿格里帕将他封锁在这个巨大的新月形海湾里。我的意思是，他为什么不主动向敌人发起进攻呢？他想打一场陆战，但屋大维拒绝迎战。由于他们的船只遭到封锁，摆在面前的选择要么是饿死、要么是死战、要么试图率领船队突围、要么进行一场海战。是的。这些就是仅有的选项。这就是那种不确定性，不是吗？因为那是公元前 31 年的夏天。
because they, they used to fighting on land and Cleopatra, this great council of war, she carries the day because she says, what? Leave my, are you mad? If we leave,
安东尼在那里。克娄巴特拉也在那里。他们被封锁在希腊西北部的亚克兴。阿格里帕的船队封锁了他们。于是他们展开了激烈的辩论：我们究竟是该从陆路突围，还是从海路突围？大多数罗马军官似乎都想从陆路突围。因为很显然，
because they can't win the war without a fleet, right? They can't win the war without a fleet. Exactly. And the, you know, the troops, the legions could retreat.
因为他们习惯了在陆地上作战。而克娄巴特拉——在这场盛大的军事会议上，她的意见占据了上风，因为她说的是：什么？抛弃我的……你们疯了吗？如果我们撤退的话……
Yeah. So that in a way way the fleet is more important so they decide that they are going to have to launch this colossal breakout and i well it's not that this is the thing it's not clear what they've decided are they going to break out or are they going to fight a naval and i'm not sure maybe you have an opinion but i'm not sure they know themselves. I don't know what they're thinking. And I don't think anyone does. Because what happens is, well, the traditional story is that they sail out and then Cleopatra makes a dash for it with her fleet for Alexandria. Antony sees it.
因为没有舰队他们就赢不了战争，对吧？他们没有舰队就赢不了战争。正是如此。而且，你知道的，军队、军团是可以撤退的。
And instead of fighting like a Roman, he then goes after her. Like a kind of a lovesick puppy lovesick puppy following his his mistress so we don't know whether that's you know is he playing the coward as octavian spin doctors have it or is this kind of part of a premeditated move to try and get the fleet out so that they can go and transport the army somewhere i mean we we just don't know but what suggests tom and i think and and i think there is a particular problem with making sense of actium because it's the foundational battle for what you know the entire augustan regime octavian becomes augustus and therefore for the entire uh dynasty that augustus founds so he and his doctors pick it up don't they it's it's
所以从某种意义上说，舰队更加重要。于是他们决定必须发起这场大规模的突围。而且，这正是问题所在：他们究竟决定了什么？他们是要突围，还是打算打一场海战？我也不太确定——也许你有不同的看法，但我并不确信他们自己心里有数。我不知道他们在想什么。我觉得谁也不知道。因为接下来发生的事情是——传统的说法是，他们扬帆出海，然后克娄巴特拉率领她的舰队径直向亚历山大城冲去。安东尼看到了这一幕。
impossible to know really and i think part of what you're saying is i don't entirely understand what's going on is that we we don't you know it's the accounts of it are not an account fundamentally of an explicable campaign it's an account of an episode that is foundational for augustus's legitimacy yeah so the sort of just to explain in very simple terms for um listeners who are not familiar with it anthony comes out with according to the accounts he comes out with about 200 ships fights this sort of battle then cleopatra comes behind but instead of him, she keeps going out to the open sea. And Antony just, for no reason whatsoever, abandons the rest of his fleet and his army,
他没有像个罗马人那样战斗，而是追了上去。像一只患了相思病的幼犬一样，追随着他的情妇。所以我们不知道这究竟是——他是在装懦夫（正如屋大维的御用文人们所说的那样），还是这其实是一场精心策划的行动的一部分，目的是为了让舰队突围，以便他们能够把军队运送到其他地方？我的意思是，我们根本无从知晓。但汤姆，这暗示了什么？而且我认为，理解亚克兴战役存在着一个特殊的问题，因为它具有奠基性的意义：整个奥古斯都政权（屋大维成为奥古斯都）正是建立在这场战役之上的，因此奥古斯都开创的整个王朝也是如此。所以他和他的御用文人们大肆渲染这场战役，不是吗？这
who are all waiting on the beach. And he heads off after her. But the thing that's quite interesting, Tom, is that the sources say that, so they shoot off. They're through the blockade. She has loaded her treasure onto her flagship. So she's got all the cash with her as well as her own ships. But the sources say that Antony, during the rest of the voyage,
真的无从知晓。我认为你刚才说的“我并不完全理解当时到底发生了什么”，部分原因就在于：我们并不——你知道的，对这场战役的描述，从根本上说并不是一场可解释的战役的记录，它是一段对奥古斯都政权的合法性具有奠基意义的插曲的记录。好吧，为了向不熟悉的听众用最简单的术语解释一下：根据记载，安东尼率领大约 200 艘船只出战，打了这样一场海战；随后克娄巴特拉紧随其后，但她没有参战，而是继续驶向公海。而安东尼仅仅因为莫名其妙的原因，就抛弃了其余的舰队和军队，
is sulking, sitting on his own and staring into it. Or do you think that, too, is part of the propaganda? Of course it is. None of this is likely to be true. Oh, Tom, that's such a debunker. is part of the propaganda of course it is none of this is likely to be true you know it's it's so you know this is this is stuff that is being produced by someone who has won a crushing overwhelming victory and who is the master of the world and has absolute you know he he he is a master of this kind of stuff uh and it's really really difficult to strip away the paint of that and see what's actually going on with anthony and cleopatra um so what we do know is they get to alexand well they get to alexandria
他们都还在海滩上等待着呢。他径直朝着她追了过去。但很有意思的一点是，汤姆，史料记载他们疾驰而去。他们穿过了封锁线。她把财宝装到了她的旗舰上。所以她不仅带上了自己的船只，还带上了所有的现金。但史料记载，安东尼在接下来的航行中，
and they go to alexandria because they they they seriously think that they can raise more money it's a bit like pompey going after pharsalus do you go to egypt because that's rich enough that there is scope for raising another fleet raising more men raising more troops and that's what they're aiming to do. But Antony first goes to, he goes to Libya, doesn't he? And he goes to try and rouse the garrison there. And with his classic lack of kind of political acuity, he doesn't realize that they'll already have thrown in their lot with Octavian.
一直在生闷气，独自一人坐着，双眼茫然地盯着前方。还是说你觉得这也是宣传的一部分？当然是的。这些事全都不可能是真的。哦，汤姆，你可真够喜欢破除迷信的。是宣传的一部分，当然是的。这些事全都不可能是真的，你知道的，这——这就是由一个取得压倒性胜利、成为世界主宰并且绝对掌握了……你知道的，他精通这种手段的人所炮制出来的东西。要剥离这些外在的粉饰，看清安东尼和克娄巴特拉身上到底发生了什么，简直难如登天。所以，我们所知道的是，他们抵达了亚历山大——好吧，他们回到了亚历山大，
I think he's been the ruler of the world for so long that it's difficult for him to face up to the full implications of his fall from grace. So then he goes back to? Goes back to Egypt back to egypt should we have should we take a break there we shall take a break when we come back i have a poem another poem from kavafi one of his most famous i think a lot of people are listening to these podcasts just on the off chance that you'll read a bit more poetry um and then we will we'll get to the the climax of the day okay see you in a minute i'm marina hyde and i'm richard osmond and together we will get to the climax of the story. Okay, see you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment.
他们回到亚历山大是因为他们真心觉得他们还能筹集到更多资金。这有点像庞培在法萨卢斯战役战败后一样：你逃往埃及，是因为那里足够富庶，还有余地去拉起另一支舰队、招募更多人马、集结更多军队，而这正是他们打算去做的。但安东尼首先去了——他去了利比亚，对吧？他试图去那里唤醒驻军。凭借他那标志性的缺乏政治敏锐度的特质，他根本没有意识到那些驻军早就已经投靠了屋大维。
It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com.
我觉得他统治世界太久了，以至于很难正视他一落千丈的悲惨境地所带来的全部后果。然后他又回到了哪里？回到了埃及，回到了埃及。我们是不是该在这里休息一下？我们待会儿休息。等我们回来后，我准备了一首诗——卡瓦菲（Cavafy）的另一首诗，这是他最著名的作品之一。我想很多人听这些播客，就是为了碰碰运气，看你能不能多读点诗。然后我们将迎来高潮。好的，一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德（Marina Hyde），我是理查德·奥斯曼（Richard Osman），我们共同主持《娱乐至上》（The Rest Is Entertainment）。
Hello, welcome back to what is the last part of our four-part epic history. I actually feel sad, Tom. Yeah. Well, so there is a sense of departure, of farewell. And this is a story that appears in Plutarch. It's said that one night Antony's there and people hear the sound of beautiful music. And this inspired one of the most famous poems that Cavafy, the great Alexandrian poet, wrote. It's called The God Forsakes Antony. Suddenly at midnight, when an invisible troop is heard passing with exquisite players with voices, do not lament your luck, now utterly exhausted, your acts that failed, your life's projects, all ended in delusion. Like a man who's all along been ready,
这是你每周获取娱乐新闻、精彩评论、明星八卦的圣地，在问答环节，我们更将揭开娱乐行业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚成立了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告音频、加更节目和优先购买现场演出门票的特权，请访问 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。
like a man made bold by it, say your last farewell to her, to Alexandria, who is leaving. First, foremost, do not fool yourself and say it was a dream, or that your ears were tricked. Do not stoop to such vacant hopes. Like a man who's all along been ready, like a man made bold by it, in a way fitting the dignity that made you worthy of such a city, approach the window steadily and listen, moved but not needy and disgruntled like a coward, listen, taking your final pleasure to the sounds, to that mystic troop's rare playing, and say your last farewell to her, to that Alexandria you are losing. So that's an allusion to Antony hearing the god Dionysus,
欢迎回到我们四集史诗历史的最后一部分。汤姆，我其实觉得挺伤感的。嗯。确实有一种离别、告别的情绪。这个故事出现在普鲁塔克的记载中。据说有一天深夜，安东尼身处寓所，人们听到了美妙的音乐声。这激发了伟大的亚历山大城诗人卡瓦菲写下了他最著名的诗篇之一。这首诗叫《神弃安东尼》（The God Forsakes Antony）。当午夜时分，突然听到一支隐形的队伍正伴随着精湛的乐器和歌声走过时，不要哀叹你的运气，此刻它已彻底枯竭，你失败的行动，你一生的规划，全都以幻灭告终。像一个一直以来都有所准备的人，
who had always been his great patron, abandoning him. Well, that's the story, isn't it? That's the story. The historians tell that people of Alexandria late at night heard this trumpet clattering in the street, and Dionysus and his revelers were leaving the city. Abandoning Antony. Abandoning Antony.
像一个因此而变得勇敢的人，向她、向即将离去的亚历山大城做最后道别。首先，最重要的是，不要自欺欺人地说那只是一场梦，或者你的耳朵出了幻觉。不要沦落到抱有这种虚妄的希望。像一个一直以来都有所准备的人，像一个因此而变得勇敢的人，以配得上让你拥有这样一座城市的尊严，坚定地走到窗前聆听，虽感动却不显得卑微，也别像个懦夫那样满腹牢骚，聆听吧，尽情享受最后的愉悦，聆听那神秘队伍罕见的演奏，向她、向你正在失去的亚历山大城做最后的道别。所以，这暗指安东尼听到了一直以来作为他强大保护神的酒神狄奥尼索斯正在抛弃他。嗯，这就是故事，不是吗？这就是那个故事。
And there is a kind of, I think the last days of, I mean, actually they're not last days, they're last months. The last months of Antony and Cleopatra do have this kind of tragic weight. Elegiac. They do, don't they? I mean, they had made a play for the world. I mean, how many of us can say that? And it had all gone horribly wrong.
历史学家们讲述的故事是，亚历山大城的人们在深夜听到街上传来号角叮当的声音，狄奥尼索斯和他的狂欢者们正在离开这座城市。抛弃了安东尼。抛弃了安东尼。
I mean, obviously, the interesting thing I would say is that they don't think at first that it's necessarily curtains, rather like Pompey, as you said before. So Cleopatra has – while Antony has been faffing around in Libya trying to raise more troops, she has two escape plans. One is she thinks about possibly going to Spain, where there are iron and silver mines, but she decides against that. The other, which is much more interesting, and we talked right at the beginning of this series about
而且，安东尼和克娄巴特拉生命中的最后一段日子——其实不只是最后几天，而是最后几个月——确实带有一种悲剧的重量。充满挽歌的色彩。确实如此，不是吗？我的意思是，他们曾放手一搏，去争夺世界。我的意思是，我们当中有几个人能说自己做到过这一点呢？然而一切却糟糕地偏离了轨道。
the legacy of Alexander the Great, she clearly thinks about going to India. She knows that there is the history of Greeks out there. She has ships taken to the Red Sea. But once again, Octavian is a step ahead. So he has suborned the Nabataeans in that area, and they attack the ships and burn them. So that avenue is closed off. Antony comes back to Alexandria. So in late 31, and they, they sort of settled back into a little bit of their old routine. So they're still feasting. They now,
我的意思是，当然，我想说的一个有趣之处在于：一开始他们并不认为这就一定是山穷水尽，这就像庞培之前做的那样。因此，克娄巴特拉——当安东尼在利比亚瞎折腾、试图招募更多军队时——她制定了两套逃跑计划。一个计划是她考虑过去西班牙，那里有铁矿和银矿，但她最终放弃了这个想法。另一个计划则有趣得多。我们在本系列一开始就讨论过亚历山大大帝的遗产，她显然考虑过前往印度。她知道那里有希腊人的历史。她下令把船只运到红海。但屋大维又先了一步。他买通了那片区域的纳巴泰人（Nabataeans），他们袭击了这些船只并将其付之一炬。所以这条退路也被切断了。安东尼回到了亚历山大城。因此在公元前 31 年底，他们重新恢复了部分昔日的日常生活。所以他们依然在举行宴会。他们现在——
they used to call themselves the, what do they call themselves? The inimitable livers. And they now call themselves the partners in death. The Sinapo Thanomanoi. That's not a word you want to pronounce. After you're drunk. Afterlexandrian feast yeah after drinking a pearl um yeah so so there they are and they're negotiating with octavian um anthony and
他们以前自称为，他们管自己叫什么来着？“无可比拟的纵乐者”。而现在他们自称为“生死相依的伴侣”（Sinapo Thanomanoi）。这不是一个适合在喝醉酒之后发音的词。在一场亚历山大式的盛宴之后，是的，在喝下一颗珍珠之后……嗯，所以他们就在那里，正在与屋大维进行谈判。安东尼和
cleopatra they sent him a crown they at some point it seems that cleopatra may have offered to abdicate if and if heesarian succeed as pharaoh. And Octavian takes the gifts, but he sends no reply back. I mean, why does he need? He doesn't need to. He has the whip hand. And then he invades in early 30. And basically, you know, we said right at the beginning that Ptolemy I had chosen Egypt because it was really easy to defend and and you know octavian just kind of
克娄巴特拉给他送去了一顶王冠。在某个时刻，克娄巴特拉似乎曾提出愿意退位，条件是恺撒里昂能继位成为法老。屋大维收下了礼物，但没有给予任何回信。我的意思是，他为什么需要回信呢？他根本不需要。他掌握着绝对的主动权。接着他在公元前 30 年初入侵了埃及。基本上，正如我们在最开始所说的那样，托勒密一世之所以选择埃及，是因为这里极易防守，
blows all that away because he just comes and defeats all resistance and by the end of july he's camped outside alexandria and it's absolutely clear the game is up and anthony so again i mean you said before that the how much of the the propaganda and stuff can you believe but the accounts like plutarch they show anthony in quite a noble light at the end don't they yeah he's desperate he's absolutely desperate to have this kind of last stand and there's this almost heartbreaking scene where he goes out with his army he has his fleet out as well and he thinks he's going to make this sort of Tolkien-esque heroic charge. And then he realizes the rest of them have all just come to defect and to give up.
而屋大维却轻而易举地粉碎了这一切，因为他径直攻了进来，击溃了所有的抵抗。到了七月底，他在亚历山大城外扎营，局势已经彻底明朗，大势已去了。安东尼——所以还是那句话，正如你之前所说，你究竟能相信多少宣传和虚构的内容？但像普鲁塔克这样的记载，在最后把安东尼描绘得相当高贵，不是吗？是的，他绝望了。他绝对渴望进行这最后背水一战。有一个几乎令人心碎的场面：他率领军队出城，他的舰队也一同出动，他以为自己能发动一场类似托尔金小说中那种英雄气概的冲锋。然后他才意识到，其他人全都已经投降并倒戈了。
Now, what's interesting is that while he's doing all this, Cleopatra has a plan of her own, clearly, to deal with Octavian. And she's got this, I mean, anyone who's seen the play the play tom will know about the mausoleum so she's built this mausoleum it's half built anyway in this sort of palace quarter and she has this plan that she's going to barricade herself inside the mausoleum with all her gold and all her silks and spices basically all the treasure that octavian will need to pay off his troops and that octavian will have to deal with her if he wants to get his hands on all the loot. And then you have this really weird series of events where, so Anton has seen everybody defect. He comes back into the city in a terrible state, kind of floods of tears, misery, all the rest of it. And then somebody
有趣的是，当他在做这一切的时候，克娄巴特拉显然也有她自己应对屋大维的计划。她有一个——看过这出戏的任何人，汤姆，都会知道陵墓的事——所以她在这个宫殿区建了这座陵墓，而且只建了一半。她的计划是把自己和所有的黄金、丝绸、香料——基本上就是屋大维用来犒劳军队所需的全部财宝——一起反锁在这座陵墓里；如果屋大维想要染指这些战利品，就必须跟她谈判。接着发生了一系列非常诡异的事件：安东尼看到所有人都背叛了他。他以极其糟糕的状态回到了城里，泪流满面、痛苦万分，诸如此类。然后有人
says to him, he says, well, where well where's Cleopatra oh she's in the mausoleum and he either assumes or has been lied to and is told that she's dead what do you think do you think she deliberately misled him or do you think he I don't know I I think it's impossible to know see I think I think there's no reason for her to mislead him I think he thinks he's just in a terrible state well i mean there is there is um there is a tradition and i can't remember which historian it may be dio says cleopatra is gearing up to have a picture octavian yeah having yeah having had a crack at caesar and anthony she's now just going for the hat trick. I mean, that's, again, impossible to know whether that's true.
对他说：嗯，克娄巴特拉呢？哦，她在陵墓里。他要么是自己猜测，要么是被谎言欺骗，以为她已经死了。你觉得呢？你觉得她是故意误导他，还是他——我不知道。我认为这根本无从知晓。我看，我觉得她没有任何理由去误导他。我觉得他当时只是处于极度崩溃的状态。嗯，我的意思是，确实有一种传说——我不记得是哪位历史学家了，可能是狄奥——说克娄巴特拉正准备去征服屋大维。在拿下了恺撒和安东尼之后，她现在打算完成帽子戏法。我的意思是，这同样无法证实真伪。
But anyway, according to the accounts, Anthony, when he hears that she thinks she's dead, he says to his slave, who's called Eros, will you please kill me? Eros kills himself instead. That's not helpful, is it? It's very poor behaviour, I would say. So Anthony then stabs himself
但无论如何，根据记载，安东尼听到她已死的死讯后，对他的奴隶厄洛斯（Eros）说：“请你杀了我吧。”结果厄洛斯却自杀了。这可真没用，不是吗？我认为这表现得太差劲了。于是安东尼便拔剑自刎了。
in the chest and he's you know this is all this is all pretty much in shakespeare because shakespeare got it all from plutarch so anthony has stabbed himself in the chest but he's not dead he's done it in an incompetent way surprise surprise so servants carry him to the mausoleum and then there's this dreadful scene where cleopatra and her two mates, Iras and Charmian, kind of haul Antony up on some ropes. This absolutely, I mean, if this actually happened, it must have been an absolutely appalling scene. There's dying Antony, blood pouring everywhere. These women dragging him up on the ropes.
在胸口，你知道，这一切在莎士比亚的剧里基本上都有，因为莎士比亚的素材全是从普鲁塔克那里抄来的。所以安东尼刺中了自已的胸口，但他还没死，他这事办得很不地道，真是意料之中。于是仆人们把他抬到了陵墓，接着就出现了那个可怕的场景：克莉奥帕特拉和她的两个同伴伊拉斯与卡米安，用绳子把安东尼拉上去。这绝对——我是说，如果这事真的发生了，那现场一定惨不忍睹。垂死的安东尼血流满地，这些女人用绳子把他往上拽。
They pull him up into the mausoleum and then he dies. And that's the end of him. But that's not the end of Cleopatra, Tom. No, because Octavian is moving in. and then he dies and that's the end of him but that's not the end of Cleopatra Tom no because Octavian is moving in so what's that do you think Octavian at this stage thinks Egypt is finished Egypt is I'm just going to absorb into my empire do you think he he thinks he can get a deal with Cleopatra he doesn't need to deal with Cleopatra I I think you know he he the public the public take is that he wants to do to cleopatra what caesar did to
他们把他拉进陵墓，然后他就死了。他的一生就这样结束了。但克莉奥帕特拉的故事还没结束，汤姆。是的，因为屋大维正在逼近。然后他就死了，他的一生就这样结束了。但克莉奥帕特拉的故事还没结束，汤姆。是的，因为屋大维正在逼近。所以你觉得屋大维会怎么做？屋大维在这个阶段认为埃及已经完蛋了，埃及——我打算把它并入我的帝国。你觉得他认为自己能和克莉奥帕特拉达成协议吗？他根本不需要和克莉奥帕特拉谈。我觉得，你知道，公众的看法是，他想对克莉奥帕特拉做凯撒对
cleopatra's sister uh asinue uh yeah decade or so before which is to um lead her in chains through the streets of rome as he celebrates his egyptian triumph which would obviously be an unconscionable humiliation for cleopatra um just as it was good for Caesar that Pompey got dispatched so basically I I think for all concerned it would be you know Cleopatra commit suicide is probably the best way out uh lots of debate about this because of course what everyone knows about Cleopatra's death is that uh she has a an asp smuggled in in a basket full of figs and pears uh and that she supposedly clasps it to her breast um and and dies uh and she dies and she's found by octavian fully arrayed in her you know her royal regalia so the famous shakespeare lines you know, to her, to her, to Charmian and is to array her, you know, give me my robe, put on my crown.
克莉奥帕特拉的姐姐阿尔西诺伊做过的事——是的，大约十年前的事——那就是让她戴着镣铐走过罗马的街道，来庆祝他的埃及凯旋。对克莉奥帕特拉来说，这显然是莫大的羞辱，就像当年庞培被除掉对凯撒有利一样。所以基本上，我认为对所有人来说，克莉奥帕特拉自杀可能是最好的出路。关于这一点有很多争论，因为当然，大家都知道克莉奥帕特拉之死是怎么回事：她让人把一条毒蛇藏在一篮无花果和梨子里偷运进来，据说她把蛇贴在胸口，然后就死了。她就这样死了，被屋大维发现时，她身穿全套皇家礼服。所以莎士比亚有句著名的台词，你知道的，对卡米安说，要给她打扮好：“给我穿上长袍，戴上王冠。”
I have immortal longings in me. And of course, these, you know, it does help her to become immortal. But the what is an asp? Traditionally, it's said to be a viper. But that would be wrong because of the poison of a viper would be would be hideous. I mean, you'd kind of you you die looking awful a cobra would be better and a cobra the you know the aureus the symbol that you have on the pharaonic headdress um you know you kind of like you you just pass away uh so that seems likelier and
“我心中怀有不朽的渴望。”当然，这些话确实帮她实现了不朽。但话说回来，什么是毒蛇？传统上说那是一条蝰蛇。但这不对，因为蝰蛇的毒性太可怕了。我是说，你会死得很丑陋。眼镜蛇会更好，而眼镜蛇——你知道的，也就是法老头饰上的那个象征——你会像那样悄然离世，所以这似乎更有可能，而且
the word would get out that she in a sense has claimed an immortality a literal immortality because for her you know for her egyptian subjects cleopatra is dying in dying is making play with these very very ancient traditions the role that the cobra plays and the mythology of it all so i think that that's what she's doing do you but i think i think it's more complicated than that oh even more complicated well i think well first of all they've had a meeting, Octavian and Cleopatra, haven't they? Well, supposedly. The day before she dies.
消息会传出去，在某种意义上，她宣称了一种不朽，一种真正的不朽。因为对于她的埃及臣民来说，克莉奥帕特拉的死是在利用这些非常非常古老的传统，利用眼镜蛇在神话中所扮演的角色。所以我想她当时就是在做这件事。你是这么想的吗？但我认为事情没那么简单。哦，更复杂？好吧，首先，屋大维和克莉奥帕特拉其实见过面，对吧？好吧，据说是在她死前的那天。
There are two different accounts. One is that she dresses up and tries to seduce him, and the other is that she dresses down and kind of cries and says, it was all Antony, he made me do it. And there's also this great story that she sort of strews the room with Julius Caesar's letters and pictures of Julius Caesar in an attempt to kind of persuade Octavian. I mean, we can't know which of these stories, if either of them are true,
有两种不同的说法。一种说法是她盛装打扮试图勾引他，另一种说法是她穿着朴素，哭哭啼啼地说这一切都是安东尼的错，是安东尼逼她这么干的。还有一个很棒的传言说，她在房间里撒满了尤利乌斯·凯撒的信件和画像，以此来游说屋大维。我的意思是，我们无法得知这些故事中哪一个（如果有的话）是真的，
but it must have been obvious to her at that point that exactly what you say, that Octavian was going to lead her in a triumph through Rome, and that she decided that would be a humiliation. And she has this dinner party, and there's the story about the old man smuggling in the snake in the basket of figs but the most of the roman chroniclers themselves don't believe in the the snake story because plutarch says people searched the room for the
但当时她肯定已经看得很清楚了，正如你所说，屋大维打算让她在罗马游街示众，而她决定绝不承受这种羞辱。她举办了一场晚宴，然后就有了那个关于老人把蛇藏在无花果篮里偷运进来的故事。但大多数罗马历史学家自己并不相信这个蛇的故事，因为普鲁塔克说人们搜查了房间，却
snake and they couldn't find any trace of it and people have subsequently said you know the egyptian cobra which is the most likely snake first of all it's hard to hide in a basket it would have to be a big basket it'd have to be a bloody big basket secondly it's not always fatal and thirdly if the stories are true and that she and her handmaidens iras and shami and all die how are you how do you persuade a snake? What if the snake doesn't bite you? And also, can the snake kill three people? It probably can't. So I think the fact that the Roman sources tend to discount it suggests precisely that it's true.
根本找不到蛇的踪迹。后来人们也纷纷指出，埃及眼镜蛇是最有可能的毒蛇，首先它很难藏在篮子里，那得是个大篮子，必须是个天大的篮子；其次，它并不总是致命的；第三，如果故事是真的，她和侍女伊拉斯、查米安都死了，你怎么让一条蛇咬三个人？万一蛇不咬你呢？而且，一条蛇能杀死三个人吗？大概不能。所以，我觉得罗马史料倾向于不屑一顾，这恰恰暗示了它是真的。
Oh my God, Tom, that is radical. Well, it's a tradition that they want to fight, that they want to say isn't true. They poo-poo it. And the true they they poo-poo it and the reason that they poo-poo it is obviously that it has a kind of resonance it has a power it means that cleopatra lives on in the memories and the imaginings of of egyptians so whether it's whether it was whether the the snake was there and they take some other kind of poison but it's attributed to this i mean who knows but i think the tradition that Cleopatra commits suicide with a snake, that's almost certainly a
天哪，汤姆，这也太激进了吧。好吧，这是一种他们想要反驳的传统，他们想要宣称这不是真的。他们对此不屑一顾。他们不屑一顾的原因显然是因为这个故事充满共鸣，具有强大的力量，这意味着克莉奥帕特拉将永远活在埃及人的记忆和想象中。所以，不管当时蛇在不在，或者他们用了某种别的毒药，但最终都被归咎于蛇——谁知道呢。但我认为克莉奥帕特拉用蛇自杀的传统，几乎可以肯定是一条
cobra. I think that I would put money that that is true, that that is part of the tradition that, you know, we've talked about how Cleopatra is mediated through mainly Roman sources. Yeah. But I think that there are obviously hints throughout the Roman sources, particularly where they deny something, that there you have a sense of how Cleopatra wanted to spin herself. And I think that she is spinning herself there as she has spun herself throughout her career
眼镜蛇。我敢打赌这是真的，这是我们讨论过的传统的一部分，即克莉奥帕特拉的形象主要是通过罗马史料塑造的。是的。但我认为罗马史料中显然处处留下了暗示，特别是在他们否认某些事情的时候，你能从中感受到克莉奥帕特拉希望如何塑造自己的形象。我认为她当时在塑造自己的形象，正如她整个职业生涯所做的那样，
as someone who is more than mortal, as someone who is part of the pantheon of Egypt's ancient gods. And she has, you know, these are the immortal longings you don't think the romans give her the snake because the snake is a recognized symbol of egypt and it just seems a fitting end to the story rather than she had a vial of why would they have an interest in doing that well it just makes a i mean some of cleopatra's
把自己塑造成一个超越凡人的人，塑造成埃及古代神灵万神殿的一部分。她有——你知道的，这就是那些不朽的渴望。难道你不认为罗马人给她安上蛇是因为蛇是埃及公认的象征，而且这只是让故事有一个恰当的结局，而不是说她有一小瓶毒药？他们有什么动机这样做呢？好吧，这只是——有些克莉奥帕特拉的
biographers think that's the case um i think they're wrong. You think they're absolute balloons. I think that we are playing with traditions that have been massively spun, and none of them may be true. But I think in this case, if there's something there that is working in Cleopatra's favour that Roman sources are denying, it implies to me that there is a tradition there and the tradition itself may be spun by cleopatra's followers but that's enough to to say that the the propaganda war well i mean what we can probably agree on is that it's impossible to know because so much of this is through layers of kind of yeah spin and fairy tale what is also
传记作家就是这么认为的。嗯，我觉得他们错了。你觉得他们简直是一群草包。我觉得我们正在玩弄那些经过大幅度粉饰的传统，它们可能没有一个是真的。但在这种情况下，如果有什么对克莉奥帕特拉有利而罗马史料却在否认的东西，这就暗示我，这里确实存在一个传统，而且这个传统本身可能是由克莉奥帕特拉的追随者塑造的，但这就足以说明这场宣传战……好吧，我们大概能达成一致的是，这一切根本无从得知，因为其中有太多层面的粉饰和神话色彩。同样
possible to say is that the power of this resonates throughout the centuries and the millennia and means that. But it's not just a resonant story because it's a resonant story. It's a resonant story because what happens next is Octavian abolishes the kingdom of Egypt. He absorbs it within Rome. I mean, this is an absolutely colossal moment in well ish i mean actually he takes it he takes it over and and he rules it as as a pharaoh
可以肯定的是，这种力量在几个世纪和几千年的时间里引起了共鸣，这意味着……但这不仅仅是一个引起共鸣的故事，仅仅因为它好听。它引起共鸣是因为接下来发生的事情是：屋大维废除了埃及王国。他把它吞并进了罗马。我的意思是，这是一个非常巨大的时刻，嗯，差不多吧。实际上，他接管了这里，并以法老的身分统治它。
well he's shown as a pharaoh isn't he an iconography he is he is so this it's not a roman province so there's no governor is that right well no senator is appointed to govern it so it's a question which is the kind of the lower order and senators are forbidden from entering it so they're not allowed to step foot in it in egypt it's exclusive it's it is octavian's private property which is basically what anthony had been planning to do. So Octavian, very coolly, very cynically, lays claim that both Caesar and Antony had been interested in, which is establishing Egypt
好吧，他在图像学中被表现为法老，不是吗？是的，他是的。所以这不是一个罗马行省，没有总督，是这样吗？嗯，没有任命元老来治理它，所以这是一个问题——元老属于较低阶层，被禁止进入埃及。他们不被允许踏足埃及，这是专属于屋大维的私人财产，这基本上就是安东尼原本打算做的事。所以屋大维非常冷酷、非常玩世不恭地声称拥有凯撒和安东尼一直感兴趣的东西，那就是将埃及建立
as a kind of private dynastic fiefdom. And that is what he does. And that then means that he controls basically the grain supply to Rome. And it's the underpinning of what will become his kind of hidden monarchical way of ruling uh and we will do an episode on we definitely will on on so just before we we clear patria herself just her family cesarean her son is murdered he's betrayed by his tutor
为某种私人王朝领地。这就是他所做的事。这意味着他基本上控制了罗马的粮食供应。这是他日后那种隐秘的君主式统治方式的基础，我们以后会专门做一期节目来探讨——我们绝对会讲的。所以，在我们把克莉奥帕特拉的事做个了结之前，关于她的家人，她的儿子恺撒里昂不久后遭到导师的背叛
shortly after and murdered by the by the romans her other children are well treated aren't they they're taken back to rome octavia looks after them and yes we don't know what happens to the boys they get taken back to rome but we're not sure what happens to them but it's selene who's the really interesting one isn't it she's married to a fellow called prince juba juba the second of mauritania yeah and they found a little kind of a little court of their own still the time of uh caligula i think doesn't caligula kill her son ptolemy surprise surprise uh because he had the temerity to wear a purple cloak or something better than him got upstaged at the amphitheater very caligula like behavior yeah um i hope you're not going to do a revisionist caligula you've done a revisionist nero tom well we i think an episode on caligula would be good it would be very good so that's the
并被罗马人谋杀。她的其他孩子受到了很好的对待，不是吗？他们被带回了罗马，屋大维照顾了他们。是的，我们不知道男孩们发生了什么，他们被带回了罗马，但我们不确定他们的结局。不过塞勒涅才是真正有趣的那个人，对吧？她嫁给了一个叫尤巴的王子——毛里塔尼亚的尤巴二世。是的，他们建立了自己的小朝廷，一直延续到卡利古拉统治时期，我想卡利古拉是不是杀了她的儿子托勒密？意料之中吧，因为他居然敢穿紫色斗篷，或者在圆形剧场里风头盖过卡利古拉，这真符合卡利古拉的作风。是的，嗯，我希望你不会去做什么为卡利古拉翻案的节目，你已经做过为尼禄翻案的节目了，汤姆。好吧，我觉得做一期关于卡利古拉的节目会挺不错的。那会非常精彩。所以这就是
end of cleopatra's descendants and egypt itself i mean actually for ordinary egyptians the transition from the end of cleopatra the seventh to roman rule do you think it was even noticeable to most egyptians not really um but i think you know cleopatraatra and Augustus are both ripping them off. They're both exploiting them. You know, they're kind of milch cows. But Cleopatra loved Egypt and the Egyptians love her and they preserve traditions and memories of her that last into the Christian period, into the Muslim period. So in the 10th century, you have Arab writers who are clearly drawing on Coptic traditions that in turn are drawing on native Egyptian traditions,
克莉奥帕特拉后代和埃及本身的结局。我的意思是，对普通埃及人来说，从克莉奥帕特拉七世统治的结束过渡到罗马统治，你觉得大多数埃及人甚至能察觉到吗？其实并没有。不过我认为，克莉奥帕特拉和奥古斯都都在剥削他们。他们都在压榨他们。你知道，他们就像摇钱树一样。但克莉奥帕特拉热爱埃及，埃及人也爱她，他们将关于她的传统和记忆一直保存到了基督教时期和穆斯林时期。所以在公元10世纪，你会发现阿拉伯作家的作品明显借鉴了科普特传统，而科普特传统又借鉴了埃及本土传统，
where she is hailed as a great philosopher, a great, great figure. And there, I think you do have kind of echoes of the kind of starring role that Cleopatra gave herself in the drama of annual Egyptian life, where the pharaoh had always played that role the guarantor of fertility of the Nile flooding of crops the cycle of the year the cycles of life and death which is why a crucial part of why Cleopatra
在这些传统中，她被尊为一位伟大的哲学家、一个非常伟大的人物。在那里，我认为你确实能听到回响，听到克莉奥帕特拉在埃及一年一度的生活戏剧中赋予自已的主角光环的回响。在那个戏剧中，法老一直扮演着这个角色——尼罗河泛滥、农作物丰收、年复一年、生死循环的保证人，这也是为什么克莉奥帕特拉能够
endures as this kind of a blazing legend well let's return let's end with the question which we began which was Judith Downey's question. She says, I bought Dominic's book on Cleopatra for my granddaughters. And before I give it to them, can you tell me if Cleopatra was a role model for girls? So Cleopatra, a role model, Tom.
流芳百世、成为这样一个耀眼传奇的关键所在。好了，让我们回到我们最初提出的问题，也就是朱迪·唐尼的问题。她说：“我给我的孙女们买了一本多米尼克写的关于克莉奥帕特拉的书。在送给她们之前，你们能告诉我和克莉奥帕特拉是否是女孩们的榜样吗？”所以，克莉奥帕特拉是一个榜样吗，汤姆？
Or where does Cleopatra stand in your estimation? I think she's a role model for girls in the way that Alexander would be a role model for boys. So a splendid role model. Encourage all kinds of behavior that perhaps wouldn't necessarily be encouraged. But I think she is one of the most remarkable figures
或者在你的评价中，克莉奥帕特拉处于什么地位？我认为她对女孩们的意义，就像亚历山大对男孩们的意义一样。所以她是一个极好的榜样。她鼓励各种或许平时不一定被鼓励的行为。但我认为她是
in ancient history. In world history, surely. I mean, yeah. And I think that her story richly merits the kind of aura of legend and fascination that it's always had. It is an extraordinary story. And I think that she was an extraordinary figure. Splendid.
古代历史上最杰出的人物之一。在世界历史上也是如此，当然。而且我认为她的故事绝对配得上它一直以来拥有的那种传奇和迷人的光环。这是一个非凡的故事，我认为她是一个非凡的人物。太棒了。
Well, I can't improve on that verdict. I think she absolutely was an extraordinary figure. Probably the greatest example in history of a woman in a male-dominated world sort of struggling to keep afloat. And actually, as you said right at the beginning, she does pretty well. She does. Egypt was literally a breadbasket. I mean, in both senses, it was very rich,
好吧，我对这个评价不能再赞同了。我觉得她绝对是一个非凡的人物。也许是历史上女性在一个男性主导的世界里努力浮沉的最伟大典范。而且正如你一开始所说的那样，她做得相当不错。她确实做到了。埃及简直就是个粮仓。我是说，从双重意义上讲，它不仅非常富有，
but it was also absolutely on its uppers. And what Cleopatra achieves is astonishing so and a brilliant story you know an amazing story not just for for adults but for children as well and i think it's wonderful dominic that you've you've written this well we should talk about and for further reading we always like to give a bit of further reading there is tom holland's two books tom holland's rubicon uh for those of you who are older than 12 or 13. And for those of you who you know people who are younger than 13, you know what to buy.
而且也正处于风雨飘摇之中。克莉奥帕特拉取得的成就令人惊叹。所以，这是一个精彩的故事，一个令人惊叹的故事，不仅适合成年人，也适合儿童。多米尼克，你写了这本书真是太棒了。顺便我们该聊聊延伸阅读了，我们总是喜欢提供一些延伸阅读材料：汤姆·霍兰的两本书，如果是12、13岁以上的读者，可以读汤姆·霍兰的《卢比孔河》；至于那些13岁以下的读者，你知道该买什么。
I don't need to sell it. So we will see you next time for more Restless History fun. And goodbye. Dominic, just one last thing is that forthcoming episode will be our version of Love Island featuring a range of historical hotties, babes and hunks. And it's possible, I suppose, that Cleopatra may feature in that. So she may be back. All right. We'll see you for Love Island.
我不需要推销它。所以我们下期节目再见，享受更多《The Restless History》的乐趣。再见。多米尼克，还有最后一件事，下一期节目将是我们的“恋爱岛”特别版，其中涵盖了各种历史上的俊男靓女。而且，我想克莉奥帕特拉也有可能会出现在其中。所以她可能会回归。好的，我们在“恋爱岛”节目中见。
Goodbye. All right. Bye bye. Bye-bye. All right. Bye-bye. Thanks for listening to The Rest Is History. For bonus episodes, early access, ad-free listening, and access to our chat community, please sign up at restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. That's restishistorypod.com. I'm Marina Hyde.
再见。好的，拜拜。拜拜。好的，拜拜。感谢收听《The Rest Is History》。想要收听独家节目、提前解锁、无广告收听以及加入我们的聊天社区，请登录 restishistorypod.com 注册。网址是 restishistorypod.com。我是玛丽娜·海德。
And I'm Richard Osman. And together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A, we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes episodes and early access to live tickets head to the There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我是理查德·奥斯曼。我们共同主持《The Rest Is Entertainment》。这里有你每周必看的娱乐新闻、评论、八卦花絮，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐业的神秘面纱，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部。如果你想享受无广告收听、独家节目以及提前获得现场门票的权限，请前往……这集节目暂时还没有评论。点击字幕中的任意句子即可发表评论。